I think that you combine what's going on
with Trump and the j6ers and uh and like
Joe Biggs and they are perhaps
intentionally creating a recipe for
disaster
they they want
an explosion I I wonder if the mentality
of these people is that either we win or
everyone loses
but why
uh
I don't know uh there's a really funny
quote from Michael malis pizzagate aged
better than russiagate I'm not saying
that's true I'm saying these people fear
criminal prosecution for a variety of
crimes like Joe Biden engaging in the
barisma Scandal the things they accused
Trump of turned out to be lies in fact
Ukraine gate was the best because it
turned out that Trump was actually the
good guy trying to weed out the
corruption and then they go and protect
Joe Biden instead so there are criminals
actively using law enforcement against
the just American people who are trying
to put a stop to their corruption